MALCOLM BARRET: My name
is Malcolm Barrett.
I'm a clinical research data
scientist at Teladoc Health.
I'm an epidemiologist, and
I'm also an R developer.
I use R packages
every day in my work,
and I'm also fundamental to the
way that I organize my code.
And the reason for
that is that R packages
are the fundamental unit
of shareable code in R.
They solve many of
our problems for us.
They make our code more robust,
easier to share, and much safer
over time.
Whether that's somebody
that's using it in the future
that we've shared it with, or
it's just us in six months.
Our code is less likely to
break in that time because
of the robustness of R packages.
And yet many people,
when they come
to the idea of writing
R package, they think,
this is too advanced for me.
This is beyond my scope.
This is beyond my skill set.
Many people also think that they
don't have something to offer.
They think that if they're
not writing something
like ggplot2 or dplyr, something
that's really incredible.
Then they don't have anything
to offer, anything to share.
I'd like to tell you a story
that comes from Buddhism.
Once, there was a
father and a son.
And at some point, the father
and the son got separated.
Here their lives
diverged dramatically.
The father became quite wealthy.
He developed a huge
estate and amassed
a great amount of riches.
The son, on the other hand,
became absolutely destitute.
He was embodying poverty.
Later on in their
lives, the son actually
stumbled upon the
father's estate.
Now the son didn't
recognize the father.
The father had changed
so much in his riches
that he was unrecognizable,
but the father,
even though his son
was trapped in poverty,
recognized the son immediately.
He tried to bring him into
the house to say, Look, look.
You can have all of this.
And the son thought
he was crazy.
He tried to run of the house.
He thought, This guy is nuts.
I don't want anything
to do with this.
So the father sent his
servants to go after the son
and hire him instead as
an employee of the estate.
The son worked his way
up from the very bottom
until many years later to
the very top of the estate.
At this point, he's the
right-hand man of his father.
On his deathbed,
the father finally
reveals to the son who he is.
That in fact, everything that's
around him is already his.
And in some versions of
the story, at this point,
the son says that he actually
has already understood that.
He has naturally
come to understand
that what surrounds him is
his wealth, his treasure.
Something that is of himself.
This is a talk about
why you already
have the skill set
from the techniques
that you use every day
in your data analysis
to pursue the path of
R package development.
In a Zen text called the
Sandokai, there's a saying,
if you do not see
the way, you do not
see it even as you walk on it.
This is to say
that we're actually
always already perfect and
complete, already ready.
So in R we might say, if
you don't see the R package,
you do not see it even
as you develop it.
For instance, you already
structure your project.
Now an R package has a
very specific structure
that it uses, and yours
might look something
like this-- your project.
I've got a data folder, a
reports folder, a scripts
folder, and analysis folder.
Now an R packages specifically
uses a folder called R,
with a capital R. And also uses
a data folder just as it is.
Instead of a report, we might
have a vignette, a long form
documentation as well as
a number of other files
that are formal, but help us
do things that we actually
often do in our analysis.
Describe it, test it,
and provide information
about how it works.
The use of this
package is really
useful in connecting the
abilities that we already have
that we use in our work to
this formalized structure
of using in R package.
So as you might imagine, one
of the most useful functions
that this project--
this package has is to create
a package using the Create
Package function.
So here I'm creating a package
called zenartrpkgs.
And it's laying out
all this infrastructure
that I need to use in R package,
and it's doing it all for me
automatically.
It's also communicating to me
very concretely, very simply
what it's actually doing,
and if I need to do anything.
One of the most important
files that it creates
is the description file.
The description file
is going to tell you
what the package does,
what it's called,
who wrote it, who contributed
to it, what the license is.
And it might tell you some more
about dependencies and more
along those lines.
It's also a really
amazing file because it's
sort of a golden ticket.
It gives you access to many
of the really excellent tools
in our ecosystem for
developing R packages.
Tools like usethis and devtools.
For instance, usethis also has a
function called Create Project.
And while this uses a
formalized structure,
it's much, much simpler
compared to an R package.
It does create in
Rstudio project,
but it doesn't have a lot of
this other top level stuff that
organizes in R package.
Notably it doesn't have
a description file,
but we can add one to it
using use description.
And what happens when
I add a description
file to a project that
actually isn't a package,
usethis still treats it
as if it is a package.
And so that means that we can
tap into some of the tools
that we're going to talk
about, about writing tests,
and other tools that we're
not going to talk about,
like writing documentation,
quite easily because usethis
and devtools will actually
treat your project as if it's
a package.
You also already write R code.
Now your R code might
look something like this.
Here I'm taking iris,
I'm grouping it,
and I'm summarizing it.
And it's resulting
in a data frame.
This is something that I
do every day in my work.
And if I use usethis, I
can put it, this code,
in a formal place using use
R. This will create an R
folder for me if it
doesn't exist already,
and put my code into it.
As well as open up this file
for me to write code in.
Instead of just writing
my code plainly,
I'm actually going to
wrap it in a function.
Functions being what you would
expect an R package to export.
So here I'm creating
summarize iris,
and I'm putting it in the
file that I just opened.
Now one of the things that's
really great about having
a package or a project with
a description file in it
is tapping into the
devtools ecosystem.
Devtools has this
function called load_all
that has a key binding
in RStudio that
makes it a little bit easier.
And what it does is it
looks in that R folder,
and it's going to load
the functions that
are in your package or your
project into your session
as if you had sourced that--
as if you had sourced
it in R code script.
And so now I have summarized
iris available to me,
and I can run it in my
council or in another script
quite easily.
You may not realize it, but
you also already declare
your dependencies.
For instance, if I
have code like this,
it often begins with a
series of library calls.
And really what I'm saying
is for this code to work,
I need the dplyr library and
I need the ggplot2 library.
Otherwise, this function is
not going to run correctly.
In a package, we can
declare dependency
by using the use
package function.
So here I'm saying,
use package dplyr
use this is adding it
to the description file.
And then it's telling me
that I have something to do.
Whenever I use a function
from this package,
I need to preface it
with dplyr colon-colon (::).
I need to really
specify which namespace
this function is coming from.
And then I'll also do
the same for ggplot2
because, of course, my code
also depends on this package.
So now when I have
my function, I
need to include the
names of these packages
as well as the double colon.
So this function ends up looking
a little bit more like this
when adding dplyr
colon, colon, and then
the name of the function
that comes from dplyr.
And the same for ggplot2.
What also is changing
is my description file.
What previously looked like
this, now has two extra lines.
dplyr and ggplot are part
of the import section.
And this is where
that magic happens
when you install an R package.
You'll notice that when
you install an R package,
you don't have to manually go
and install every other package
that package uses.
R is smart enough
to look at this file
and install those
packages for you.
And so that's
exactly what happens
when you install a package
from CRAN, or from GitHub,
or from another source.
R will actually go and
look for these packages
and install them for you.
You can also use devtools
to install them manually
using the install devs function,
which is extremely useful.
Now you may not realize
this part in particular,
but you also already
test your code.
This might be one where you're
thinking, Wait a minute.
I don't really even know
what testing your code means.
I'm not a software engineer.
I don't write unit tests
when I do my analysis.
I don't test my code.
But actually we test
our code every day.
Often in a situation
like this, I've
got this function clean data.
And I'm giving it
the iris data set.
And something obviously
has gone wrong here.
It's giving me an
error, and I don't quite
know what the problem is.
So I actually need to
sit around and think
about it a little bit.
Usually at this point,
I start fiddling around
in my counsel to see if I
can actually make it work.
I will give it a different data
set, or change a few things,
or look at my code, and
really try to understand
why isn't this working?
So I go back and
forth, and I really
iterate through this process
to try and get it working.
And it turns out in this
case, if for some reason
I removed the fifth
column, it actually works.
My data is now clean.
But that just makes me
think more, why is that?
And so I'm going to again go
through that iterative process
of figuring out, what's
wrong with my code?
How can I get it to work?
What do I expect
it to look like,
and what does it
look like right now?
What you're doing is doing
a unit test of your code.
You just aren't writing it down.
And so the process
of writing unit tests
is to formalize this
iterative process
of kicking the tire of our
code to making sure that it
works the way that we expect.
Now unfortunately,
often the way we
do this analysis
is when it breaks.
But writing unit tests helps
you write code more robustly
because it helps you kick
the tires all around the car.
Not just in the tire
that has a leak.
The used test
function will help you
create a test in the right spot,
set up all the infrastructure
that you need from the
test of that package, which
is one of the most popular
testing libraries in R.
Put everything in
its right place,
open up for this file
for you, and set it
up so that you can
automate your tests.
So if I go in I write the
informal test that I just
did in the command line
directly in a test script,
I can now run the test
function from devtools, also
which has a very convenient
key binding in RStudio.
It will load the package for me,
and it will run all my tests.
And now I can know if I
make a change to my code
that everything is still OK.
I've got a green light still.
Or importantly, if I
don't I know what's wrong
and where it comes from.
There are great many ways
that you can use the R package
system to extend what you
already do in your analysis.
But these are three
really useful techniques
that you can really get
off the ground with.
The first is using
a description file.
This lets you provide
metadata about your project
or your package.
It lets you tell us what
your dependencies are,
and it gives you access
to this whole ecosystem,
such as loading and testing
that is available to you
when you're developing
an R package.
Write your code as functions.
You're already using functions
in your every day work.
So this step is to
actually take that,
wrap it in your own function.
And finally, write
down the tests
that you're actually already
doing, and then automate them.
Take advantage of
the description
file of this ecosystem
for R packages,
and automate this process.
What would be the next step
in coming home to R packages?
Taking advantage of this
treasure that's already yours.
We put together a workshop
called my organizations
for R package that's
really focused
on developing internal
R packages, personal R
packages, things for you, your
team, your research group,
things like that.
So I recommend checking
out this resource.
And I also highly,
highly recommend
looking into the second
edition of the R packages book.
In particular,
the first chapter,
which is called
whole game walks you
through the whole process of
creating R package from A to Z.
And it's great, and will
help you get off the ground
right away.
So this is my invitation to you.
Write an R package, whether
it's for your own personal use
that you'll never share
with anybody else, perhaps
for your team, perhaps changing
a project into a package,
or creating a package
to help with a project.
Or maybe you've got
a great idea that you
want to develop
out into a package
that you're actually going
to share with lots of people,
and maybe even submit to CRAN.
This is my invitation to
you, is to try this out, walk
this path, and take advantage of
this incredible resource that's
already available to you with
a skill set that you already
have.
Chögyam Trungpa, a
Tibetan Buddhist teacher
had good news and bad news for
us in our meditation practice.
The first, the bad news
is that you're falling out
of an airplane, you don't
have anything to hang onto,
you don't have a parachute,
and things seem pretty bad.
But the good news is
actually there's no ground.
There's no way that you
can fail at this process.
My name is Malcolm Barrett.
You can find me on Twitter,
GitHub, and my website.
Thank you for coming,
and good luck.